okay hi everyone again continuing our
season of design reviews we are now
looking at video
and image processing
and maybe sound i don't know we'll see
we're video editing right now
okay so video replace
is something that can replace a segment
of a video now with another video is
that correct
that was the case before now you can
specify
a segment and replace it with a still
image
just as a handy utility
i see so that so time has not changed
i'm a little bit confused before if you
have a video
and the place you're replacing into is
only five seconds long and you've got a
one hour video what happens
uh we had two fitting modes one of them
chopped the video the other one
stretched
um the interval
okay fine
so clearly with an image this is always
a stretch type thing
this is always just fitting that time
duration yes
okay
okay image take
so so look there stephen the whole set
of image things
now accept video objects
that whole
group below there
so what about something like
chromaticity plot 3d
more things no that that's not supported
now more things we're going to be coming
back to in a second round
considering whether we want to map the
function over
frames or do something more sensible
over time
combining information from multiple
frames
3d i would imagine what it would do is
just average it over the whole you know
movie
right average it or get out all the
pixel of all the frames that would be
right yeah yeah yeah right exactly
which again should do some dimension
reduction before it plots all of that
but yeah
again
these were the obvious ones
that
we're just mapping over frames of the
video more of these things will be
coming should be coming in the future
rounds
i mean
so things
like mean so
if i say edge detect on a video
in the future you imagine that that
would just edge detect every frame
that wouldn't be wrong yes i think that
could happen yep
um
like remove background could just remove
every the background every frame
now
that would be one function that i would
debate should we find the common
background that across all frames or at
least across frames of every scene
and then do remember i agree i think it
would be a luxury feature
to have it do something other than frame
wise
right remove it
and i mean
like image identify
i mean if it's a cat from many angles
it's still a cat
and you want a single cat come out or a
list of all the entities that are
identified at different frames
and should we delete duplicates see
these are all the obvious questions
that on many of these
i guess about 200 functions now
we need to answer before we can
make more of these accept videos
fair enough
net encoder now does video wonderful
image dimensions
how does it know i mean what happens if
i want the second video track
uh that's not acceptable unless yeah at
least that's not available as an option
in image dimensions
one could construct a video object with
the second track being the only track
for the first track
by video select video track selection
option so you can say video of the file
name comma video track selection goes to
two
or a list of two comma anything it we
always take the first available track in
the video object
does scene change work in video frame
list do we talk we talked about this
last time a bit
we did
um
in an internal discussion you suggested
add changes
for scene change which is documented up
there we were internally discussing that
ad changes
um
might not be
obviously
always immediate so someone was
recommending changes instead
i think typing changes would be easier
as well
okay so hold on
so you're saying
frame specifications are
these does not make sense as parts of
speech together
uh sorry i didn't uniform and changes
don't i don't go together oh oh okay
i mean how does that work
um
oh maybe it's okay with changes i guess
what do you think roger
i think it's okay
changes
i i i think it's not
nobody's gonna really misunderstand that
and
you say uniform sampling which you don't
say changes sampling
no
i mean
it would be better if it was uniformly
randomly
yeah i was thinking that
that would be easy to change and we
could still easily support the synonyms
yeah i know but hold on
video frame list
gives a list of n images okay
you know
why isn't this
it would make more sense
if this was something like
[Music]
video frame list
blah comma
and then
56 something like arrow uniform
what about something like that
where else do we have that i'm not sure
reminded me of the max features max
items that we have as well
maybe we could utilize them if you don't
like the proposed syntax
however max items max features make
sense here not as much in
snippets video
which is
having a very similar design to this
well the issue is
look the other possibility would be to
say something like this
and then the issue is the alighted case
of that
because
i can imagine also this case is somewhat
useful
or do we don't have a default for n we
don't have a default for n we don't
so they can we imagine
do we think
changes could work
changes without an n could work
and that's documented in that table too
obviously we need to use a default
threshold for when we assume a change is
a change
but other than that yeah but that's a
separate option what's that option
um oh that i haven't documented i think
in this design that you see in the
notebook it's going to be a list of
three values changes comma n comma t
i i think i've documented that in
snippets video
okay but the default case of changes
and no n
so we changes all and then the threshold
all right i guess this is okay with
lists and just call it changes
okay
okay
ethan is complaining that there are no
corresponding loss functions for net
encoder for videos
more on video and neural net is coming
a lot more hopefully it's coming but not
in this version yeah
okay
ethan is also asking about pose
estimation do we have anything on that
uh no
although do we have any networks in the
repository for that i think we do
actually now that you say i think
at least one if not more than that in
the repository
given that we have face
you know facial features and things we
we could have pose detect
could we not
i i don't know why not sure
actually the obvious thing will be
closed recognized those recognized
perhaps i'll have to look into neural
models as well and see what's out there
it does seem useful
okay
image fitting what is that
what is
actually can you open frame fitting that
was the one we introduced i think 12 2
or 12 3
and we're proposing a name change from
frame fitting which is
um
which would make sense in the video
domain but we actually need the same
option in image domain
so what does it do yeah
um
if you're enjoying letterboxing
you know all the black stuff around it
how is it going to fit it
won't fit with an image in an image
right but what's the function that you
are
that it's it's being put into
this is
the one you're looking at is transcoding
i'm asking for the image case what
function are you going to put it into
um conform images is one and that had uh
i think
i think this proposal is not for any
specific image function yet but
when we are combining images liking
conform images again has an argument for
fitting
however one could imagine having this
image fitting as an option there
okay but what have we done
elsewhere
in image trim and image
reset all those things
isn't there something where you have to
decide whether you tile
re-tile the image and so on
image image assemble has that too
yeah the magical large image assemble
okay but there's a different one which
is something
where you've got padding for the image
right
yes
right and isn't isn't this
you know
fitting is a concept
it's not i mean
padding isn't padding a concept you also
use for audio and stuff like this
yes
why isn't it documented here
um
probably should be right it's it is an
available option for audio
yeah although those illustrations
doesn't say this is
not for audio but i agree it should be
more explicit and maybe exemplified
well also this thing here doesn't
mention audio
and in fact when it comes to video we do
need both frame padding as well as time
padding
so we have debated a couple of times
there is no proposal for that but i
think some kind of an association
setting that says temporal padding frame
padding
as two sub parts of that would be useful
but padding
is the analog of fitting is it not
how do you
yeah go ahead i think padding is the
scheme of padding um fitting says
how to how to fit
and then depending on how we fit then
we're going to have
we may or may not need any padding
around the image but things like image
collage don't they have a fitting idea
concept as well yes
but that's so far all of those have been
arguments not options
bring up the page steven because i think
there's a useful table
for which page image image fitting
frame fitting oh we didn't okay
no
no no that's not let's look at the
source
because that doesn't have the
illustrations let's
okay
i think image fitting is an
incomprehensible name
and it also is a fit of a different kind
you know what i'm saying we've got a lot
of fits
and it's even got a fit fit so it's a
fit fit you know
yes right
um
and it's been an argument in most other
places correct
yes
and
i mean well i could imagine such a thing
for a raise as well
why not if you've got two arrays this
would be a useful thing to do
it's like a two paddles
yeah it's like it's like a block
diagonal matrix of some kind
or you know something like that
um
i mean conform
you know
um it's conforming to certain dimensions
dimension conforming
well but it's not it's
i mean you know conformation function
might be a a
possible thing even though these aren't
in fact functions
how crazy is that
because we can imagine something where
you're given
in general you're given the image and
it's
a target bounding box
and then these just happen to be the
names that you use for it for these
cases
or it could be
i mean just like we have um
for panel
it's a panel
yeah i see this is another kind of worms
related to this is this content padding
business
is this related
i mean the whole question of padding
which comes up a bunch in
graphics and you know when you have to
align graphics and so on i
i kind of think we need a padding summit
of some kind because i think there's a
bunch of different things like this
i don't disagree it could be discussed
along with all of our spacings and
framing and all of that as well what to
put in between
yeah well right but i mean how much
how much
plot range padding and all that all
those kinds of things
i mean this is not padding this is
confirmation this business here
correct
i'm favoring confirmation function
it's a bit pompous but but um i think it
says what it is
the only thing that comes to me is that
if you look at image conform audio
conform
or con
conform images it's the other way around
conform audio um
there are more properties
there are more properties than just
the size that can be conformed now do we
want conformation function to
conform like in its more generic form of
a function do we want it to conform
anything possible well you could call it
confirmation method if we wanted to
simplify it a bit
i i think i like that better and then
mostly accept string settings in some
cases if
okay
so i think that's more correct yes
and then this would go in here
confirmation method and it isn't just a
confirmation function being fed into
form images and then the confirmation
method
would be
this would be what instead of that
argument it could be it could also have
a confirmation method
would be one of these
all right
although at that point it's really the
method for conform images
well i understand we should support this
as an argument whether we bother to
support that
as an option i don't know
okay
but this is essentially a peel-off
option where it was supported as an
argument for in this function but when
it is peeled off it is an option
yep
okay
image stitch
okay uh
ali is asking for image processing
capabilities so now we're talking about
them
okay image stitch
i do like all these illustrations that
you guys are coming up with it's really
good and we should have you look through
in other groups roger which other groups
could do with illustrations
now
we we haven't really achieved scale yet
for
for what to catch up with
on our on our own and we keeping it
under sort of tight control to not slide
too much in quality
well quite
i mean these are not easy to make
no they're not
um they require close connection between
the person who understands what's going
on in the artist who's actually drawing
them and we spend a lot of time i spend
a lot of time reviewing all of these at
this stage until until we feel confident
that we can i think it's i think it's
look it's it's
words are hard enough pictures are even
harder yeah
when they work though
the the speed to comprehension is quite
fast and that's what i
no i know i agree with you
i mean
you know
as you might notice the nks book is
absolutely full of of uh you know
diagrammatic explanations of things
absolutely yes many of which took a
while to figure out
right
and we've had to iterate these quite a
lot
right i think one of the things that's
tricky in these pictures is that you are
including you know one of the nice
things about the nks book pictures is
that they are
purely from sand up so to speak they
don't have anything representational in
them
whereas in these pictures you have to
have something representational
otherwise it's incomprehensible what's
going on
right
okay anyway so image stitch
i see
so
why is panorama different from scan
because of the because of the
some kind of angles yes
why is it when it's at a distance why is
it any am i being confused why is it any
different when it's at when the objects
you're looking at are far enough away
am i being stupid about that
do you understand what i'm asking why is
the
what's the limiting case does it yeah i
agree with you so it should have less
of an effect when it's far away
but but but does it deal with things
being nearby
so it deals with
i am totally confused here as you look
around
i am so confused
as i
if i'm at a fixed point
and i turn my head
i do not obviously do not get different
parallax of the objects i'm looking at
right
yes
so i don't understand why there's a
difference between these two cases
what what is the different thing that
you're doing in those different cases
i mean that's magnificent
that's absolutely magnificent
wow
does it always work that well
we'll have to still stress test it it's
been in the in the bills a week
as of a week ago
but um as you see at least in those
cases it it really seemed there are if
you scroll down there are a list of
steps that we go through
to
what achievements i don't understand
what's happening here and why is view
center in quotes
um yeah that's that's an internal option
that's
that is to say which image should be
taken to be the center of the image
and you're saying this panorama thing
the borders oh i see it i see i i
understand what's happening i understand
what's happening these pictures are
projected onto a sphere and so there's a
projection in general
yes
as soon as jose
gets
you know the sphere as opposed to geo
functionality working
right you should be able to have sphere
projection
arrow whatever here right so given those
pictures you should be able to show you
know a lambert as immutal projection of
whatever city that is
i'll look into it is that coming in 13
i don't remember i haven't seen much
about it i mean the point of sphere
you know the idea is sphere distance as
opposed to zero distance and the only
difference is that geo distance is
really referring to the planet on which
we live where a sphere distance will be
a sphere of radius one by default with
um you know with angles and radians and
things
geo
distance seems so very specific but
given that
you know
100 of our customers are either right
now on the earth or in orbit around it
i think we are that's the one we want to
use
um
does this run reasonably fast
yeah
so we're going to have a
progress indicator for it it doesn't
have it now i i think that one is gonna
run in about 10 seconds or so
that was pretty good that was faster
but how does it know
to distort
so it understands that distortion up
there
wow
that's pretty neat so now what happens
if i want to cut out of this thing
just the region where i've where i am a
full rectangle i don't want any of this
winged nonsense here there are there are
very many different ways of
uh drawing a full rectangle in that and
we have to define
which rectangle to pick the one with
largest aspect ratio largest area
uh the one that gives most of the image
as opposed to the other ones
but i would assume you always want most
of the image i mean you want the
but then the most of the image might be
the very
short thing on the top i see what you're
saying is that there is a there is a
rectangle it just is long and thin
i see okay are there options for this um
not yet
i guess we're leaving this um well we
might be implement we might be able to
implement something but not within the
next four days
um
what is transformation class
that's to restrict whether you want only
translations or rigid or other types
like perspective that was in version 10
yep that was when we
introduced image line i think
okay
okay so so hold on so this
um
yeah
ios on livestream is saying that they
didn't
even though these are beautiful pictures
they didn't understand that this is a
spherical thing and that's a flat thing
and i agree that that is an imperfect
aspect of those pictures at this time
and you could you could indicate this by
drawing the kind of the the guide marks
of a sphere around this and the guide
marks
of a square grid around this one
sure
and also not showing those edges
straight
um
okay so let's let's um
okay let me understand this
so
wait a minute so you're saying so so
there are various issues
so in terms of stitching the things
together i think i understand that now
what what is this view center thing
the view center thing you can put any of
those images on the center say this is
the question of which one is deformed
and which one is not exactly
okay
and that's
as you see that's a string thing not
documented yeah but it's the wrong name
but we actually have view center
yeah it's a different completely
different means something totally
different
um
so
okay so the issues are
which which is the undeformed
i mean that's very much related to this
whole projection question
because in general you could take the
whole thing you get
okay
this is what's relevant in the case
where there is a spherical
you know where the image is imagined to
be on a sphere correct
yes
as opposed to so so the different cases
are no it could be a planar one as well
and you mean the transformation classes
only
no no i mean look look the things that
i'm imagining is you've got a flatbed
scannery type thing and you've got a
thing that is moving over this flat bed
right that is one case there's no
projection involved there everything is
just you know you might align it in a
certain way but there's no there's no
spherical projection stuff right case
number two is you're turning your head
and you have a single
you have a
essentially a point light source or in
this case a point camera
that is turning around
and then is observing something which is
spherically projected
i really think i wonder if
can we see if jose might be available
uh yeah i can try
okay
um
okay so actually ethan is commenting
about the confirmation thing
um
changing yeah and changing encoding and
things like that
in confirmation of videos how does that
work
in addition to the size the confirmation
method of size
what about
i don't know color i mean
aren't they you know like all those
things you see at the end of movies you
know the different color models and
things
right isn't there
in what way are you conforming videos
with respect to encoding color models
frame rate etc
things like that are controlled in video
transcode
some of those options are available to
our video generators not all of them
we decided we'll leave them mostly for
video transcode
but
the issue is is the name confirmation
really the right name given that it is
the purely the size
story
i think we could go beyond just the size
again with some kind of an association
syntax we can have multiple properties
specified
and if it's just a string it could be
the size
or just the list in fact it could be a
size
okay
okay fine all right so that's a future
enhancement for that but otherwise it's
it's some
uh
uh
transcode okay
um
yeah sandra is commenting on on this
name view center which is right now
crazy is something like
center image or something but but
apparently jose is away today but i mean
the issue is we have exactly the same
you for projections of the earth right
how are you going to center the
projection
you see what i'm saying yes right
um
and if i look at geo projection
i think geoprojection kind of hacks it
in the sense that it says
given
a particular projection don't you just
say
um
look at the options then probably
yeah by the way we should different
comment but we should probably have
documentation for each we should have a
documentation subpages for each of the
each of the um
uh projection types
yeah
uh
actually
should no no i i we we've been talking
about that we want to bring out mappings
okay transformations and these are
non-linear transformations
and it's a big collection
right i mean in this particular case the
way you center one of these is just by
giving a list pair as i recall
right like if i'm saying i want you know
a conic equidistant projection
[Music]
where does it even say how this works
oh centering here we go
oh boy
so there's a centering option
what is all this is this is what i'm
afraid of right this is what i'm afraid
of here
is there are many other different kinds
of details here
the central scale factor
you get what i'm saying
it is more complicated i believe
yep
um
okay
so that that view center is not going to
be an exposed option here i agree we
should look at what you just opened and
talk to us
what we are doing now by default is that
we put the image which has strongest
connection to other images in the center
fine i i you know this is what for this
version we should just do the obvious
thing
sure
i mean i think um
uh
oh boy
that's a complicated issue as well i
mean that's
see this is again a confirmation method
type question
is how to conform the color
you know the color levels and so on
yes i mean like like if you have an
overlap and one of them is slightly
redder than the other what do you do
there are a couple of things that happen
there there are brightness equalization
there is color balancing
color equalization and there is blending
at the edges
okay fine by the way this i mean
previously we had image align
right which was which was kind of
a way to do a piece of this is that
correct
um yet a piece of this if you wanted to
do stitching but also image a line on
its own has use in
aligning images before say 3d
reconstruction or doing things like
focus stacking
um
what is that and other things
what is this doing or this thing of
where we enhance the lights
since i don't understand what is this
doing yeah
click on the output
it it finds it places the second image
where it matches the first image
i see
i see okay so it's a small piece of
image stitching
yep
that is a very obscure first
output
yeah i've looked at this page multiple
times and i know i've not noticed this
i don't know how you deal with that well
maybe
you're right
no i think we can especially now that we
have image stitch i guess we have been
adding image stitch examples here as
well
with that focus but i think we should
make this more of an uh more of a real
really alignment between images that
need to be aligned not for stitching
purposes yeah by the way if this was a
smaller piece of this image it would be
more obvious what's going on
you're right you're right
or maybe some kind of a superimpose with
a proper border around the other one
yeah why not
this one has a border and that one
doesn't have a border and then it does
the right thing and that slices the
water off and it it'll be obvious what's
going on that's a very unobvious example
yep i agree
oh gosh this is another projection
isn't it
yeah it's scan
no i know but but it's not
rectilinear is it
no it's not it's got a how does it know
that those things are tipped over
it doesn't need to it's how the image is
captured right it's like a fl it's like
a drone it's like a player i realize
that i really like scanning
i'm asking the question
maybe it's just me being
this image here
is that precisely this here without
tipping
yes it is yes
but then these ones are tipped
because of the way the sides work
correct
boy okay this is subtle
it's lovely i mean it's really lovely
the way that it deals with these
these you know
projection things
okay well that's the beginning of a long
descent i mean it really should be
sphere projection i would imagine
that option that'll be the same as the
one for the all the sphere capabilities
there
um
okay ethan is saying multiple times here
making sure switch stitch
works for full spheres
obviously you need a spherical
projection in that case don't you
i mean in other words if you have it
i'm very confused here so so then okay
so then the question is can you make it
work with dynamic image
there are a couple of requests here
basically
um image stitch we discussed it with
marcus multiple times the output is
going to be a single image and no other
modes now do we want to have things like
spherical image stitch or cylindrical
image stitch
uh in in which i guess we could return
other things or maybe an image plus
coordinates that gets mapped to a
cylinder or a sphere because there are
obviously additional things that are
going to be needed to say how in the
cylindrical stitching that's okay so
let's walk through the multiple things
which are involved here okay so you got
an image
and
you in principle you could texture map
it onto a sphere
right then you could be looking at
different parts of the sphere you would
do the same thing as geographics we'd
have a sphere graphics which i think
we're planning to have anyway
and sphere graphics would give you all
of the same kinds of projection
capabilities that geographics has
does that make sense
and one could even imagine
a dynamic sphere graphics
which would do exactly the right thing
and allow you to essentially i mean
although the controller might want to be
different from the controller for
geographics i'm not sure because you're
typically in a you know in the earth we
are small compared to the earth right so
we tend to move around
in dynamic geographics we just want to
pan and zoom
around small pieces of the earth
typically
hold on do you wanted a planar
projection like we do in geographics you
didn't want a 3d interface where you're
looking around
well i mean
by the time we have vr and so on we'll
want the 3d interface
but this is the same issue as astro
graphics
right because it's it's inside the
sphere
as opposed to the earth where you're
looking at it from the outside
right so
it seems to me that there are different
what one wants is essentially
a representation of the spherical
texture
which we don't specifically have for the
earth we represent that you know our
maps are implicitly
correspond to what's on the surface of
the earth
but we don't have something where
we just give it a symbolic blob of data
i mean you
know look the concept would be spherical
image presumably
and what is that do you think
like i think
it's it is the um the 3d interface or
the flat thing
no i think it's a symbolic object
okay spherical image would be a symbolic
object which is like the sky you know
assume that the sky was a
you know assuming you're in a fake
universe or something and the sky is
painted and you're looking from the
inside
that's what i imagine spherical image
would be
but then you can
navigate around that like we do exactly
exactly so this is 3d okay fine right so
what i'm suggesting is that spherical
image
would be
so i mean
you know spherical image would then just
be whatever data it needs to represent
the 360
you know version of one of these images
possibly within complete parts
and then what it outputs by default
presumably like geographics would be
some projection of the spherical image
okay so there's a second stage there
why would it
say so you wouldn't get a 3d interface
you would get a flat interface
i think the default output should be
flat just like the default output for
geographics is not dynamic geographics
well dynamic geographics is still flat
i know it's still flat
and
the question of what the controller is
look spherical image
is a great segue to vr basically because
that's what you want in vr
if i'm not mistaken
yep
right so in other words what we could
imagine is were there to be a reasonable
vr format which i'm not sure there is
there's
one of these days i mean it's completely
crazy that they don't that hasn't
existed that it's been like put objects
into a unity scene or something to make
vr
it's crazy that there isn't a bitmap vr
there must be a bitmap vr standard by
now what is this
so app smaller the file form as we see
the apple is supporting i forgot what
it's called now
okay fine
but then
yeah right so so that's what we then
need and then spherical image should be
exportable in that format whatever it
is and then you're
you know and obviously once once one can
routinely hook up a vr thing to one's
computer
then you know who knows what we're doing
then with notebooks and and images
within notebooks of this type
but um
uh
yeah sandra is commenting about turning
spherical photos into planet projection
photos the difficulty with that is i
think it's this is why i wanted jose
here
i'm i'm always confused by this
astrographics and geographics are not
the same
one you're looking from outside the
planet and the other one you're looking
out at the sky
and i think the spherical image case
is the case of most interest is out of
the sky
because
the only case in which
well there is the other case okay the
other case is kind of the taiyo like
photography case where you're looking
all around an object yeah this is
complicated this is complicated they're
really two cases there's i'm looking all
around an object
i have a drone photographing or a 3d
scanner photographing all around an
object
from outside in and the other one is i'm
looking around my scene from inside to
out
and i think those are two different
cases
see what i'm saying and i think they
require different controllers and one of
them you could imagine a controller that
is like you know a trackball or
something where you are moving around
on the floor we did one under texture
there's a thing called the skybox where
we
simulate that thing we're sitting in a
box and you're looking outside it's like
a glass box okay
however i really think if you're
scanning from outside and you always
stay at the you you view at a
perpendicular angle the reconstruction
of the two are gonna be is gonna be the
same
i don't know i still also have to wrap
my mind around it but i think really
the the reconstruction is going to be
the same for both
i think the controls will be different
i think so i think it's interesting to
think about sort of workflows here the
controllers are i agree but the
reconstruction i think is going to be
the same and yes roger
because i think what's going to happen
is for example given a 3d surface
you're going to want to generate a
spherical image of the 3d surface
that would be an example
because that's the interface that you
would use to put it into vr for instance
yeah
but vr is just that you're sort of
navigating around from the inside
that's correct except that but we also
have this sort of the specimen you know
our 3d graphics is more like specimen
you you're rotating around a little
specimen
right but the point is the point is you
are moving you you are walking around
the specimen right yes as opposed to you
are in one place and you are turning
your head
and in vr
what you get to do with the vr headset
is you are in fundamentally one place in
the first approximation and you're
turning your head
right
right
and with the cameras that we added in
version six we can do either actually
we'd wear 3d graphics
the camera we had prior to version 6 you
had to be outside and look in
right
um
the comments from our
live stream here
about
um
let's see one comment from owen
i think this is about exporting and
knowing
encodings and things like that
has to look at what encoding it is every
time they export an image or video i
don't completely understand otherwise
what encoding did we end up using i'm
not sure why one cares
um
let's see
uh
luis is asking is it possible to
mathematically change the pixel values
and get back an image yes use image data
and then image on the image data
that is very easy
um
okay how would this work for
stereoscopic dot mpos
3d asks
what is the story what are mpos that's a
file format presumably
dot mpo have we heard of it
uh no
what is the story with story so this
particular thing of image stitching oh
boy that's another weird case
is stereoscopic images
and image stitching
yep
not yet handled i think
weird
i mean
stereoscopic has gone
in and out of favor ever since the 1880s
i think the first the first boom was in
1880 or so yeah there was another one in
the 1980s
yes
um
and maybe
i don't know
it's it's hard to to say who
look basically the basic point is as
soon as there is a serious vr ar headset
that is
has the form factor of a pair of glasses
as the form instead of the form factor
of a helmet
yeah you know things will change
it will
it will yeah
and i'm not sure anyways
yeah i completely agree but how much it
is related to image stitch i don't know
i think we do want to create
stereo stereoscopic versions of images
when we have lefts and rights
uh that could be easily viewable with
those gadgets
but that's a different thing from
stitching them together
yeah yeah i agree i agree i agree the
stitch i'm just trying to understand the
future given what the nice thing you're
showing here yep
i mean you know the future is presumably
spherical image
perhaps
the outside in and inside out variants i
don't yet understand that
and then a whole variety of ways to view
those things and ways to project those
things
yes and and my feeling is that rather
than feeding i mean perhaps
the projection capabilities of spherical
image could be fed into directly into
image stitch but i would not think about
those as part of image stitch
see what i'm saying
i would think about them as part of
spherical image projection
and then
you know again things like how the
centering works and all that kind of
thing so the only issue is you have some
additional information
from in stitching because you know what
images you started with
but
you know where is the coordinate system
right if you're going to specify the
center
and you've got 10 images and they stitch
together and now you want to say i want
to center my spherical image here how do
you specify the here
right because you don't even have a
coordinate system you don't even have a
pixel coordinate system to specify the
here
and what you're doing now
with this little bit hacky thing i think
is to specify
you want to be
what you'd want to do is something more
like inset we want to say i want to be
at this pixel position in this frame
in this image right in other words you
can give a coordinate system you have i
mean it's actually kind of funny these
are coordinate charts in the sense of
you know whatever differential geometry
whatever whatever your favorite right
these are that what you have
is a collection of
the pixel positions within each stitched
image each
stitch input image right each each image
being stitched is a coordinate chart
defines a coordinate chart
yes
pretty much
right and so if you say in this chart
this pixel position
then you have defined a position in the
final image
right so yes to be able to say the
center
of the final image
were you to want to say that
you would give that as a chart number
and a pixel position within that chart
yes that would work
so i wonder if we have an option that we
could use given that you seem to have
these capabilities within image stitch
that
is some kind of image center type thing
i mean that would probably be the name
right image center arrow but it's a
little weird that you'd be giving
uh
see but actually what you want is just
like inset what you want to be able to
do is say
yeah here's here's what you want here's
what you want you want to be able to say
and it's more like a key point mapping e
type thing you want to be able to say
this position in this call in this
coordinate chart
goes to this position in the final
target space in the single chart which
is the final target
potentially you might want two different
places
in the you know in the original charts
to map to two specified places in the
final single chart output
does that make sense
clearly there are many degrees of
following what's that yeah okay let me
follow let me explain this is not
difficult okay
so imagine
that
i have
that's one position there okay that's a
pixel position
you know uh chart two pixel position
blah blah
okay
and then this here is chart whatever
that is eight
pixel position blah blah
right
yep okay for each of those things i
could want to say
in my final image
these are the pixel positions that i
want those things to land up at
because my final image has more degrees
of freedom than just saying where this
one wants to end up
you see what i'm saying
yes
okay that's interesting stuff all right
ethan sends us examples of spherical
videos
gopro has a spherical option i guess
um
sander has already made three 360 vr
videos with language and sends us a link
that is cool
um
ah that's interesting okay and sanders
says there's a community post here
which
um
in which sander has
managed to
oh
lovely
oh
okay
much to understand here
interesting okay
cool
um
okay
uh owen is saying not encoding but file
names i think you have to be more
explicit because i don't understand
um
and
it's talking about
nasa heel picks is a convenient way to
pixelate a spherical surface okay that's
interesting
um
uh let's see
wow what is this
oh wow look at this
do you know about this
i have seen this before yeah yeah i've
seen this thing before this is this is
this is important to the satellite
imagery folk
are you aware of this stuff
charlie
i i haven't looked into this before but
i can comprehend what that is yes
okay because i mean obviously if you if
you have
equal area and lat long
yep it's it's unfair to the poles
yep
um
on the other hand if you're solving the
kelvin problem of equidistributing
charges on a sphere that's also too
difficult so i imagine this is some
compromise there ethan is commenting the
main non-vr
use case for virtual interactive
walkthroughs is real estate websites
yeah i mean the the two cases that i'm
aware of are that and product
you know the
right so there again they're outside in
and inside out cases
right
i mean i have to admit i've already seen
these in in demos from
from tech companies but i haven't seen
them in the wild but i imagine when you
buy a pair of shoes
that you get to see all around it with
some kind of um
uh i have to admit i don't know i'm too
too pathetic in terms of that kind of uh
online
shopping but um i i would imagine that
there's a way to use what is effectively
a ball type controller to be able to
look around an object again from outside
in yes
and with the real estate stuff that's
all
inside out type stuff traditional vr
i mean you don't usually
you know you could have a thing which is
the drone flying around your prospective
house or office building or something
which would be again more like a a
shoe-like view so to speak
but i don't think that's the primary
case
um
okay well so so for this function
right now
i see so you've got various method
option cases
uh right
right so those are very basic options
there
yep um
so in this case here
you're giving a hint basically about
what the arrangement of the images is
that correct correct
so what about the following possibility
what about the possibility of giving
like a sparse array-like format
where because you know you might have
for example
you've had a drone go around you know
either a drone or you have some kind of
control system thingy that's you know
it's a microscope it's moving around and
it knows where it is so to speak and you
might end up with something which says
coordinate arrow image
yeah i think that's going to be more
useful than the
sparse array case i think if he can have
uh possibly either a list of rules with
positions goes to image or
um
or an association
that would be more useful i think that
the other case of sparse array you said
we probably have most of the images and
some missing so we could easily support
missing in the array anyway
sparse array as well should be supported
but um but some kind of a coordinate
rule
uh
the missing thing or the none would be
useful in the image array
and
the um sorry and a sparse array version
of that and
rules of the form coordinate goes to
image yes
and in general what you want is that
same kind of insert specification
because it in in a perfect world you
would know the coordinates and you would
say where in the image
where in the in the chart coordinate
system
does
that
lie so to speak yeah but for the
coordinate
for the
list of rules with coordinates we'll
have to have the anchor point of
the individual images too that's the
point you were making earlier yes so
that's what i'm saying i'm saying that
that what you would do is you would say
you'd have to say
i think
well okay so the natural thing would be
something like
um you know
x y
goes to image the problem is where's the
anchor point in the image
do we have a way of specifying a point
of interest in an image
don't we have a way of specifying in the
image of poi
no
the one thing we have recently done in
video overlay is to use the wrapper
placed
and we do say where to place the image
and spec as a third argument specify
that
that's another thing to look at we are
we are way over time here
um we have a question from marco
uh
about uniformizing colors isn't that one
of these options here i mean in other
words if you if you want to get rid of
that square artifact there what do you
do
well i mean that's a that's a land of
machine learning and other kinds of ways
to blend images i would imagine yes
which
we have some version of but we probably
still need to work on
this is a great function
um
all right we still got more stuff to go
over here i'm afraid
how much more is there
um well
well if we want to return to video so
the stuff that remains is not that much
but if we want to return to video
uh
okay 3d by the way on our live stream is
talking about mpo
is multi-picture object format
i see
i'll look into it oh look at this this
has a
it has two jpegs side by side with
certain parameters
like multi-angle disparity something or
other
stuff
so it's got metadata it's got exif like
metadata i imagine
um
okay
uh
great we've got another i think we have
another hour of the stuff
what do you think roger i think so too
okay
and then another hour of graphics tour
video
yes if we're gonna make graphics to a
video it's i i think graphics to a video
is
is hanging by a thread at this point
and i would suggest that graphics to a
video for this version
be some kind of function repository
prototype
it'd be great if we can get it i just
think that there's a lot of degrees of
freedom basically you are describing a
path
in a graphic
that is a complicated thing in its own
right
you've then got all kinds of random junk
of you know we're going to have to talk
about frenet frames and the relationship
to angle path 3d and all kinds of stuff
it's going to be complicated
right because that that is
that is a version of what we're now
talking about with spherical image and
so on no no no no it's 2d it's 2d
it's a
okay for now it's a 2d walkthrough yeah
the 3d is significantly more
okay so there's no frenetis there no
so it's a 2d turtle not a flying turtle
yeah
um
it's still going to be complicated
because it's going to have it's going to
have velocities and things like this
going around the curve
well i mean what i pre yes i mean for us
to
to review this we need to sort of have
rich of a richness of examples
because
[Music]
one can make these projects and
functions arbitrarily complicated no i
know i know but i mean
that's not the goal what what do you
want to do if you know people do this
routinely you know to make their you
know
kind of
flat
you know image presentations more
exciting as they kind of wiggle around
in these images right and there's a you
know there's a
uh so we've done this ourselves for um
trade shows which in case our graphics
department have done some of these
things right
well we should figure out what they've
done what paths they used exactly
we should ask them i mean i'm sure
that's just code
i mean we did long ago it must have been
15 years ago we did that actually very
nice actually that's a good example
the um
the graph
of the demonstrations we should look at
that video because that one was was i
mean that was all programmatically done
and it was
fairly well thought out
because what it did was in that
particular case what it did was it went
across this giant array of
demonstrations and then it zoomed in on
one of them it held for a while zoomed
out went to another one and so on right
but that's why i'm saying we need sort
of use uses and shows so there are a
couple of examples yeah i mean i think
that that case where
you are zooming in on a particular
feature
like is
a not uncommon case
exactly that's what we have i'll create
i'll create a few examples for next time
let's at least spend
15 minutes on it yeah but i also tend to
agree with steven that i don't think
it's fully baked in the sense that
unless we really use it ourselves it's
not going to be that great
um
by the way just to comment for the
project management folk here it really
will be useful to make sure that there
is a folder in which to put these things
and to know what that folder is
yeah you could
um yeah video i can take it from there
for now i i know that but that's not the
useful i mean that's not where we want
it
and probably what we should do
is to actually pre-create a bunch of
folders in here which are for our
top-level guide page categories and
worst cases we can use those
okay oh look at this just made a video
graphics tour yesterday says sander
why is it wiggling around so much
because it's bouncing to keep something
constant
sounds like you're following that ray or
something
it's it's almost like the camera is on
the right you know yeah right
there's also sea sicknesses here yeah
that's great
it's great though yeah it's a really
nice picture
in the video very nice
very interesting too
um
right
okay great stuff all right until the
next time
thank you all and
thanks
to folks on live